one guy who will not be in chicago this
year mitchell trubisky the second
overall pick in the 2017 draft if you
haven't heard he was taken before
patrick mahomes and deshaun watson
trubisky signs and i was surprised by
this because this is a
clear backup job this is no opportunity
to start
there are not going to be any questions
of trubisky along those lines at his
press conference
trubisky signs with the buffalo bills to
back up josh allen here is bill's gm
brandon bean explaining the decision to
target
the former bears starter this is a reset
for him
and we don't expect him to be here long
term this is a kind of a one year
probably not in his plans when he was
drafted where he was
but we hope it's a great reset for him
sean uses it you know
make you be you know the best version of
yourself here in buffalo
and then you know hopefully in a year
he'll get a chance to go back
and and land a nice contract and a
starting job somewhere
you know we have no doubt that that'll
happen but we're excited to add him
here in the mix it's always hard to read
demeanor but i was watching sean
mcdermott during all that i don't know
how all in he is with
his squirmy and looking around and like
man and we don't know what he was
thinking about in that moment but if he
was thinking about
true whiskey being the backup he's
thinking man we're screwed if we get to
that but i i
i kid because trubisky's been to the
playoffs two of the last three years
trubisky stabilized things last year for
the chicago bears he's not
horrible this it's just funny how these
quarterbacks
that that end up being on teams that
aren't
superstar teams are just painted with
this broad brush if you
suck and i don't think it's fair to
dalton i don't think it's fair to
trubisky they
they are above the you suck line they're
not
mahomes they're not watson they're not
brady they're not
rogers but they're not
the worst of the worst they're not blake
bortles
sorry blake but they're not you know the
guys that you look at and say oh my gosh
why is he on the football
field yeah well it's funny you mentioned
blake bortles because that is
the player that i thought of with this
contract situation because
in 2019 when the rams signed blake
bortles part of the
the thought process was well he's got a
lot of starting experience
you know we think he can come in and at
least be a viable option for jared goff
if something happens to jared goff and
then you know we saw how the rams
quarterback situation turned out but
the thought was he comes in he rehabs
his image under sean mcvay and maybe
the next year he goes and he gets the
starting job somewhere at least gets the
chance to compete for it and that's
really exactly what brandon dean was
talking about with mitchell trubisky
they don't necessarily expect him there
along they think that he can come in at
least be a viable option because
of all the starting experience because
of the two playoff appearances that
he's led the bears to so you
think at least you know and he can run
as well so you think at least if
you know heaven forbid something happens
to josh allen you're not going to be up
a creek without a paddle you're not
going to have the same size paddle that
you did before with josh allen but
you'll at least have something that
can get you down the river a little bit
until josh allen were to come back
yeah and when you have a quarterback
like josh allen who is fearless who
takes hits who is mobile
who could get injured you need to feel
good about
the backup that you thrust into the fray
and
mitchell trubisky greater than sign
matt barkley it's that simple it's that
simple
and you feel better with trubisky as
your insurance policy in the event
that josh allen gets injured because we
see it all the time and i don't want to
be accused of jinxing josh allen but
we yeah quarterbacks get hurt and it can
happen it happened quickly
to uh to dak prescott last year and so
you need to be ready for it and the
cowboys had andy dalton and
not that it worked out for the cowboys
but dalton didn't embarrass himself and
it helped dalton get the 10 million
dollars he's going to get
from the bears this year we found a way
to tie it all back and finish where we
started
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports